long ago in the wintry North an army of
demons emerged from beneath the icy
ground and spread darkness and despair
across the land
astride their monstrous spiders flanked
by Giants they wreaked havoc on the
innocent slaughtering thousands
all hope was lost until the Fearless
Warriors of the first Night's Watch
drove them back into the wintry
mountains and built a magic wall to keep
them from ever invading again
these stalable brothers in Black
continue to protect us even to this day
from the evils that lurk in the shadows
an absurd lie a fairy tale spun by many
a wet nurse in the North
to be sure a giant wall does exist the
Triumph of engineering perhaps but not
of magic
as for the Night's Watch
there may have been a time centuries ago
when there was Prestige and honor in the
miserable monastic life of a black
brother but now the wall has become a
glorified penal colony full of outcasts
criminals and assaulted nedu Wells
I want to thank the sponsor of today's
video and an awesome game raid Shadow
Legends explore millions of champion
combinations and master countless
tactics as you take on raid bosses
dungeon runs and campaign battle with
hundreds of artifacts to equip and over
600 Champions blessed with unique skills
you can build your team develop your
Champions and raid your way use my QR
code or links below to download raid
yourself to your mobile phone or PC I've
been playing raid for a while now and my
favorite Champions are cavallax and
Raglan one of their most notable skills
being opposites cavalx being the most
poisonous player in the battle and
Raglan being the best healer if you got
your hands on Ultimate Death Knight you
can instantly update him use the DK
Rises promo code for a bunch of free
items to level your Ultimate Death
Knight all the way to level 50 and 5
Star Ascension if not don't worry this
promo code has enough resources for any
character you got and right now raids
running an amazing trick-or-treat
promotion Halloween where new players
can win a bunch of real life and in-game
prizes including one thousand dollar
amazon gift cards and some of the best
epic and legendary Halloween champions
in raid anyway it's all free and easy
all you need is your raid player ID this
special event runs October 15th to
November 5th new players use my link or
scan the QR code and get a free starter
pack worth almost 30 dollars a free
champion verges and also this school
in-game loot you'll find these rewards
here in your inbox for the next 30 days
only all you have to do is click the
link in the description once you Reign
you can find me in game under the name
Fire and Blood and if you're fast you
can join my clan unlike our Southern
Rivals the Stark Kings of winter didn't
Forge the north into one Kingdom for
Glory or gold there is little of either
here but to survive alone in Westeros
the north remembered when worse than
dragons lay waste to armies
thousands of years ago the sun set on
the Realms of men and the long night
began
a new race emerged from the ice and snow
the white walkers they demanded no Crown
offered no terms spared no life and the
dead marched with them with Humanity
facing extinction as Stark sought out
the children of the forest the most
ancient beings and Westeros and convince
them to Ally with the men they'd once
fought together the two races pushed the
Walkers back into the land of always
winter and sealed it off from the Seven
Kingdoms with the wall
300 miles of ice stone and Earth rising
nearly 700 feet tall
to guard it they established the Night's
Watch a Brotherhood sworn to defend the
living from the dead whose vows are
raised both titles and crimes
after the long night the north tried to
forget it belonged to a continent
perhaps who Pride perhaps through sheer
ignorance he never can tell with the
North
swords in the Darkness
hi
the black Brothers of the Night's Watch
are that at least when he lies down at
night he can't have nobody to warm his
Frozen bed
well not unless the crawls like to Nest
together
you think he remembers the stories they
told him then
about when the white walkers woke in the
land of always winter and how the wall
and the next watch were raised to stop
them the next time
never mind trapping us on the other side
Marie free [ __ ] have our stories too
about how one of your king crawls found
something called no words
bright blue eyes
how he brought her home through your
wall and declared himself Knights King
13 years he and his Queen ruled over his
brothers making sacrifices as black as
their clocks lucky for you Southerners
the free Fork rallied to a King Beyond
the Wall as we will when need be and
March on the ancient castle he'd taken
for his own the night fought
with the help of the Starks we killed
the demon and cleansed your precious
watch
and then they thanked us
and kicked us back across the wall as
you always have
night Gathers
and now my watch begins
it shall not end
until my death
I shall take no wife
hold no lands father no children
I shall wear no crowns and win no glory
I shall live and die my post
I am the sword in the Darkness
I Am The Watcher on the walls
I am the shield that guards the Realms
of men
I pledge my life and honor to the
Night's Watch
for this night
and all the nights to come
Legend
tells of a winter that lasted a
generation
and of a vast and terrible darkness that
fell across the land
it came to be known
as the long night
in the midst of this Darkness
the white walkers emerged from the far
north
with their armies of the Dead
they waged war against the living
laying waste to Villages and old fasts
leaving Terror and destruction in their
wake
after years of brutal conflict and
unbearable loss an alliance of the first
men and the children of the forest
managed to drive the Walkers and their
minions back into the frigid Northern
wastelands from whence they came
to prevent another invasion
the first men erected the wall
a massive fortification 700 feet in
height
stretching from the frost Fang mountains
in the West to the Bay of seals in the
east
it was a Structure unlike any ever built
indeed some maintain it could only have
been completed with the aid of giants or
using the powerful magic of the ancient
children of the forest
men were required to guard and maintain
it
and thus the Night's Watch was born
a sworn Brotherhood tasked was defending
the Realms of men against the dark
Forces that lay Beyond
upon taking his vows a brother of the
Night's Watch serves for life
it is a life of hardship and great
sacrifice so the oath must not be taken
lightly
the punishment for desertion
his death
joining the Night's Watch or taking the
black is a singular honor for any
northerner
for it was in the north some 8 000 years
ago that the first man drove back the
white walkers erected the wall and
established the sworn Brotherhood that
would guard the realm at its people from
the dangers Beyond
regrettably the knights watch no longer
commands the widespread respect and
admiration it once did
while house Stark and other houses in
the northern regions continue to
recognize its vital importance to the
safety and stability of the realm
this view is not shared by the powerful
houses of the Southern kingdoms or the
subjects
most regard the Watchers are misguided
obsolete order made up of useless
outcasts
admittedly the current Night's Watch is
a shadow of its former glory
the maesters don't believe in Prophecy
with good reason
the children of the forest supposedly
could see into the future yet were
surprised by the first men who nearly
ended their race and the long night
which nearly ended us all
Masters posit that the children's
magical site was invented long after
they vanished from Westeros by singers
hoping to Thrill peasant girls
not that most Masters have much
experience in what does or doesn't do
that
war did not come to West us with men
in the dawn of days the children of the
forest fought to the Giants
deny the race so to destroy the other or
they claim to the continent couldn't
children hunted and fought with dragon
glass arrows and Spears and the Giants
had ordered the branches they pulled
from trees
nor could both races feel more than one
of the Seven Kingdoms of today
then the southern deserts coughed up a
new race the first men would cross the
narrow sea over the armagedorn the first
men had never seen the rare wood but the
children had never seen bronze the
dragon glass arrows glanced off the
first immense Shields and their armor of
woven box split we need the first men's
swords as the war raged the children
resorted to the one advantage they had
the magic of their old
the green seizures enlisted direwolves
and snow bears cave lions and Eagles
mammoths and serpents in return the
first men cut down
burnt everywhere what they could find
fearing that the children would spy on
them through the faces in the trees
children became desperate the green sea
has called down the hammer of waters to
break the armored door destroying the
bridge that men crossed into Westeros
and to flood to the neck
to contain men to the South but the
first men would not be stopped
fearing Extinction the children combine
their powers for one last spell that
would save their people and their land
from The Invader
made by themselves the children were too
few to resist the onslaught
but if they could turn men's numbers
against them
after hundreds of years and Untold
deaths production the wisest heads of
the children and the first men finally
prevailed the children couldn't win this
war and the first men didn't want to win
fearing the costs and Victory
Heroes and rulers on both sides met upon
an Isle in the God's eye to form the
back
children gave up all the lands of
Westeros save for the Deep forests and
the first men swore that they would no
longer cut down the werewoods
thus ended the dawn age and began the
age of Heroes
yet after the dawn must come the night
the great evil that the children
Unleashed in the war returned centuries
later and only an alliance between the
children and Men defeated it
foreign